when i i don't know that people know
this but i i did years ago i i did the
movie gremlins and i'm gizmo oh yeah
yeah
it's gizmo yeah but you know i had to
audition to get that and i auditioned in
a building in burbank not unlike this
building here and i didn't know that it
was a medical building and the casting
person had rented an office in the
medical building
so i was going for the audition for
gremlins and it wasn't just
me to play gizmos all that all the all
that but as i went up the stairs
all i heard is a woman's voice going oh
oh
ow
that's all i heard and i thought oh
she's going to get the part
and then
i uh it was so is right next to an ob
gyn some gynecologist and she was having
a procedure i assumed she was having a
procedure yeah maybe she wasn't maybe
she's just a complainer sitting in the
waiting room yeah yelling out
yeah but uh and then i i got the part i
went into the wrong office i went into
the gynecology no i did but then they
said no next door because i was the only
guy i went you're going i can beat that
she's going out and i'm going come
did you uh did you practice that voice
before you when did you kind of just go
on the fly no i didn't practice that's
the only voice i do you know people i
think we talked about that before i do i
was it was part of my act i was
11 years old and i was at a birthday
party and i was choking on a piece of
cake and you know when it goes halfway
down your throat and then you can't
dislodge it i think there was something
in there
you know when something's happening
so i was
and they were doing that they were
laughing i'm saying help me
and you're laughing everybody at the
party was laughing i'm going i can't
breathe there's something halfway down
my throat
please help me
and and they were laughing that sounds
like what i heard through the wall with
the pornography group actually that
exact quote really
that exactly
there's something halfway down my throat
and then and then i dislodged it and and
but when i went home my memory was the
trauma of almost choking and dying but
more importantly what stood over that
was everybody at the party was looking
at me and laughing at me and i thought
oh my god if i could just bring myself
this close to death each and every night
i could be an entertainer i could be in
show business i could so i i practiced
without my
uh without cake so you know you can do
it it's just like you take the nipple of
a balloon you know when you blow up a
balloon and you stretch a balloon
so that's not my voice i'm not i'm not
talking like
no it's not doing that if you close your
throat
can you try it
better
this is a really bad asmr
wow but it's good the weird thing is
there's some star trek fan out there
probably getting erect right now
so i now i i did that voice and that
became part of my act and then uh i did
i got a job on a show called muppet
babies oh and i'm i'm skeeter
i'm skeeter oh
skeeter is that yeah you know is peter's
kind of the ones he's he yeah he's more
he's multi-gender he's everything kind
of oh what is his pronoun oh i think his
pronouns is just
everything i'll go moss you know it's
like everything in spanish i think
wouldn't skeeter didn't have a gender
did he
i i don't know yeah so that was that was
the voice i don't know i don't know what
i am
my pronoun is everybody there you go
yeah okay so uh that was skeeter and
then a couple years later i got bobby's
world and i decided to use the skeeter
voice so i did this since the scooter
this is bobby yeah and then years later
when i saw my gynecologist i got uh
gizmo and i did
so they're all the same a whole array of
voices i did other voices on the uh on
muppet babies yeah i was also bunsen
honeydew oh i don't remember that would
you bring up bunsen please honeydew if
you don't listen to me i'll make your
sister disappear
it was that and i was a animal oh bye
bye
bro
and then i i
i was busy and i was on the road and
then uh who took over for me on that i
think it was dave coulier you guys
almost look the same now he does look
like me i didn't realize that
bunsen honeydew looks exactly like me oh
[ __ ]
your bad is so [ __ ] great i never you
might have to rebirth you might i gotta
do it oh my god it's me
look at me
how did it saw the future the puppet is
designed you gotta see bunsen honey dude
they could see this they're watching
this on youtube right yeah art imitates
life man that's the oh my god i didn't
know holy
it's like my new headshot there you are
yeah that is going to be my new headshot
rich is in there richard works with me
we got to just give out bunsen honeydew
pictures
oh my god look at all of them what are
you getting what is all that
and there's merchandise oh that's google
i'm just look where you went to the
beach so you can see me tanned up a
little bit there
in some of those yeah oh my god i was a
good looking i had no idea that i was
voicing my own future
and that's me
well i think that's not baby buns was
there a baby bunsen it's muppet go
muppet babies bunsen honeydew that's the
regular um bunsen honeydew i was a
muppet babe there i am
even more
even more like me
and there he is with an eight ball too
and that was obvious damn look at the
glasses yeah i have my own
an eight ball if you're going through a
tough time yeah you know we talked about
it before we went on the air mental
health i've been dealing with it from
the beginning and look there's
mentioning there's my new glass line
i had he was you know i got into the
glasses business did you eyeless just
people are going totally eyeless now
well that's why he needs glasses he has
no eyes
he only uses those for i i've never seen
somebody wear glasses without actual
eyeballs
until you bro as a baby that's me that's
who you were well because i didn't want
to be called four eyes i wanted to be
called noah no eyes i like that yeah but
this is uh i started
also predicting the future so i'm doing
that character i had no idea that one
day i would shave my head there is one
hair on there isn't there at the top is
there one hair there seems to be like oh
yeah do you see that
yeah if you pull that it undoes my belly
button
yes
and then uh
and then i didn't know i'd have my own
line of glasses and my online glasses
wow that'd be so funny if you pulled
that
and your belly button just came on
haven't you ever done that have you ever
cleaned the lint like there's i get a
lot of lint in my belly button and and
sometimes when i start pulling the lint
out i unravel my underpants that's
insane
what
you've never done that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one